oh
à chaque jour des milliers de personnes
prennent des routes souvent dangereuses
pour fuir mais pays
c'est lé plus grand déplacement de
population et puis la deuxième guerre
mondiale
or ces migrants aux nouveaux risques et
la mort sur la route que de l'attendre
la leyre pays ravagé par la pauvreté la
violence les guerres et les catastrophes
naturelles mais des pousses en plus les
pays devaient fermer leurs portes
minsk qui permettait d'accéder au rêve
américain
we are going to be et gris bordeaux
[Applaudissements]
we do pointe m enow country
mais lui la règle immigrés
sont vos dirigeants qui encourage
immonot président à nous faire souffrir
c'est comme ça on aurait dit non on va
chez vous alors cette fois-ci by step up
winz refuse un baptême au canada
canada le canada christ est l'une des
rares pays encore plus sûr qu'on perde
au caire et à gaza
si je préfère aller au candidat au
canada en amérique c'est là où je vais
mais pour se vendre des milliers de sans
papiers implante une autre qui traverse
onze pays du continent américain
at elle avait le genre
campagne
et montagne
si migrent à atteindre le canada est
définie on rêve
les canada dry
les rêves canadien
juriste de l'adil affirmé hier que le
chef sa queue
ça fait plus de six mois qu'on a
commencé à préparer ses
ces voyages ont rêvé d'aller dans un
pays qui parle français
vous dressez les canada s'est déjà 42
ans et j'aurai recette vient dé quitter
sao paulo au brésil et le voyage avec
son marigot des indes réfugié politique
à l'ère des mondes
nous avons changé leur nom comporte tous
les migrants qui apparaîtront dans ce
reportage
brochettes et godet ont fuit la violence
du congo il voyage avec leur fille
pauline et marie les recracher traverser
le brésil le pérou jusqu'à l'équateur
puis la colombie l'amérique centrale
vers le mexique
les etats unis est en fait le canada on
voyage des plus d'événements km avec une
coup de chance ils arriveront à
destination
à moins de six mois rochette a tout
laissé derrière elle est équipée du sa
foi et de sa bible pour affronter la
route
oui ces versions et fortifie beaucoup
quand une idée je suis tout lien qui est
fou les rares la plante de votre pied
je vous les donne comme je n'ai donné
amusé d'autres parcours
ce kit tout hollywood qu'elle je
marcherai de ce qu'il est et renaît et
savait de moi je serai toujours leader
[Musique]
pour recettes comme des milliers
d'autres s'appliquaient cuba et haïtiens
san paulo c'est l'endroit sont les
continents amérique où les rues
empruntées par les migrants convergent
c'est d'ici qu'est partie non pour
ferrer long et pénible voyage vers le
canada ou les états unis
ils sont arrivés au brésil alors que les
pays se préparait à accueillir les
olympiques la coupe du monde de soccer
et notre cv ma internationaux la
construction d'infrastructures leur
permettait de récolter l'argent
nécessaire pour répandre la route
aujourd'hui le travail se fera à la
maison de migrants de sao paulo une
offre non seulement des repas mais aussi
des conseils et des ressources
c'est un oasis qui permet aux migrants
de s'arrêter et de prendre une pause
pour récupérer ces énergies avant de
reprendre la route ce qui est important
pour nous c'est d'offrir un soutien aux
migrants qui peut avoir besoin dead et
d'appui nous les aidons à conserver leur
autonomie pour qu'ils puissent continuer
leur voyage
profites était administratrice des
finances avant de fuir les congo à sao
paulo il nettoyait les toilettes une
hôtel pour faire des économies
conçoit élabore en uniforme ont une
égale et bourses
[Musique]
je suis allée la toile et du plein jour
ce que vous trouvez comme ça
[Musique]
quatre hélices à l'oscar dû second
mandat
c'est qu'elle etats unis canada je mets
préparés l'épée que j'ai je connais pas
du tout je sais que ceux souffrant
comédie qui suit pas facile parce qu'on
fait des jours à pied c'est pas quel
parcours ont fait déjouer à pied c'est
pas facile
saint-aunès des îles se pose toujours la
question est ce que ça vaut la peine de
mettre ma vie en danger connaissant une
chaise vide mais quand les conditions de
vie ne sont pas dignes ils cherchent des
alternatives qui risqué leur vie
c'est l'une d'elles dans sa terre risque
à jeddah
je décourage paraît pourquoi des risques
pareils la vie bon et bien sûr et quand
vous mourrez c'est fini
vous restez fini sur un symbole ou
précisément au brésil
radiomee quand nous sommes là claudine
et animatrice à la radio et le crois
qu'ici les pays ouvraient leurs portes
des migraines ne serait pas obligé des
risques et lévis enfin les guerres nous
voir des tragédies
nous fouillons des gens qui viennent
pire
[Musique]
oh
l'écrivain
[Musique]
sentent pas reconnus
rien mais décourage français c'est
plaisant malgré les avertissements elle
va partir il croit que sa foi et son
meilleur atout pour affronter la route
avec la prière il tente de surmonter sa
peur de l'inconnu courage et même des
bois bowman était un bel ajout souhait
là où tu fous les ratés pied je serai
avec toi obodji je confie cet appareil
pour la complice aignan est ce que moi
je sais
[Musique]
maintenant cet ego d'aînés voyage
personnes vers le canada oui d'autant
réfugiés congolais les accompagnent mais
ils ont peur de montrer leur visage sans
passeport et sans documents de voyage
les groupes d va tout faire pour éviter
les contrôles migratoires et les postes
frontaliers des informations qui nous
viennent d'ailleurs que continuent à
venir
il ya des amis qui sont passés par ces
chemins qui nous informe qu on envoie
des messages
moi sa propre surface il
no mais mon nom
nous nous débrouillons même sur google
je suis déterminé parce que j'ai un rêve
avec moi
[Musique]
devant la maison rochas et magna prête à
faire face à sa destinée je m'appelle
rosette g41 arrivé au canada avec mes
deux filles
[Musique]
ma
quito capitale de l'équateur depuis plus
d'une décennie
cette ville est devenue la plaque
tournante de la migration irrégulière
dans la médina
les migrants et les réfugiés qui passe
par ici arrivent d'un peu partout
la majorité d'entre eux poursuivent leur
projet sans passeport les documents de
voyage ils ont tout intérêt à se
déplacer les plus rapidement possible
pour éviter les contrôles migratoires
procès ne fait pas exception
elle passe un couvent d'une gare
d'autobus à l'autre
c'est pour les enfants et pour vous
c'est pour les discussions par les
discussions d'autres migrants doivent
s'arrêter à quito pour gagner l'argent
nécessaire afin de poursuivre leur
voyage
certains finissent par y rester et il
aurait donné vie à des quartiers ce
quartier s'appelle comité de louis blot
donc que c'est le premier cas tiers
temps les haïtiens l'entrée dans le pays
les isles on aime ce quartier parce que
cette occasion guerre commerciale et la
zai vers le business molière petites
sommes et pastor il dirige l'église de
dieu à rêver certains de ses paroissiens
à quand le moment propice pour les
prendre là l'autre
une grande portée de hasard il
s'entretient il faut ce qu'il ya une
force en eau que les f à marcher et à
faire cette auto à faire ce chemin
avec les migrants sont arrivés les
passeurs les coyotes comme on les
appelle dans la région ils ne sont pas
trop visible mais ils sont là selon
certains pays il est démis grâce un
papier a franchi illégalement les
frontières on les appelle des boîtes
parfois on les appelle des poulets boîte
ou poulet c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
les migrants à la recherche d'un
meilleur avenir pour procès est une de
ces passeurs il est membre d'un groupe
qui accompagne les migrants du sco nord
de la colombie
l'épi entre 1800 et 2500 $ ou tropiques
ya plusieurs routes pour éviter les
contrôles nous savons où elles sont nous
savons aussi quelles sont les meilleures
pour se déplacer et bar où il faut
passer pour pas avoir de problème
joe sumatra
ces traversées illégales font en sorte
que personne ne sait avec certitude
combien des migrants cité par quito mais
les organismes humanitaires estiment
qu'il y en a eu au moins 12 familles
depuis quatre ans
[Musique]
concept sa famille un igloo des
congolais ont atteint la ville de toul
quatre là sont frontalières de
l'équateur avec la colombie vous avez
quand même
bonsoir
avançons
avant même d'arriver à tout le temps
rochette avait déjà vécu sa première
expérience avec un groupe dépassera au
pérou et nous allons rentrer la matière
la création des personnages moi j'étais
petit j'avais peur de secours que la
page
ça dépend aussi des roches est une
afrique s à ce qu'une documents de
voyage doit avoir à nouveau recours aux
services des passeports pour éviter
d'attirer l'attention
la frontière entre l'équateur et la
colombie est poreuse l'absence des
mariages permis aux gens de circuler
librement
mais il faut éviter les gestes suspect
les mouvements venus n'est pas sot passe
à l'action
aborder ces taxis procède de sa famille
traverse la frontière clandestinement
vers amis ni attendent déjà
de notre côté
procès a eu de la chance les soirs même
les autorités colombien mise en place un
barrage routier pour effectuer des
contrôles aléatoires
dès que ses souhaits il n'y a aucune
garantie que le rêve de migrants se
concrétise il peut faire affaire avec
des trafiquants mais il ne peut pas
savoir si ce sont des gens honnêtes
il ya beaucoup de trafiquants malhonnête
en faisant affaire avec eux le migrant
signe en quelque sorte son arrêt de mort
les sans papiers qui contourne la
frontière sympa sort ne sont pas moins
ça risque nous avons retrouvé un
migrants haïtiens qui avaient emprunté
un sentier lundi il s'était arrêté pour
se reposer et avait placé ses mains sous
sa tête en guise de rigueur
l'hypothermie la tuer le plus triste
c'est que ses amis ne l'ont pas attendre
il avait peur de se faire prendre place
les migrants qui traversent en colombie
sont d'origine de plus en plus variés
mais pas les miens et des séries télé et
des somaliens ont touché été arrêté
planète
hayden a tendance à l'augmentation des
contrôles a donné naissance au service
des transports haut de gamme pour les
sans-papiers plus fortunés trente sept
mille dollars
les migrants disent clairement mené
jusqu'à la frontière américaine n'est
pas chaud andris ces spécialistes dans
les transports des migrants chinois en
groupe on s'ouvre de groupe formé de
personnes de plusieurs pays
notre patron habite un autre continent
chaque groupe et responsable du
transport de migrants dans son propre
pays n'est qu'il operator colombien ils
travaillent sous les ordres de la mafia
chinoise
si un de nos passagers tombe malade
nous devons payer ses frais médicaux
commence lui vend c'était travail risqué
pour nous et pour notre famille
parce que nos patrons nous sauver
[Musique]
après sept mille kilomètres recettes et
sa famille arrive à méditer
au terminal d'autobus une surprise les
attend arrivé à mener nous avons passé
la nuit au terminal médine passe
exactement hiver la nuit il n'y avait
pas moins d'acheter les billets parce
nous n'avons pas de laissez-passer pour
acheter les billets pour l'obtenir c'est
laisser passer qui permet de séjourner
temporairement au pays crochet volet de
se présenter au poste des frontier dès
son entrée en colombie mais assez
plaisante en danger courez le risque
d'être ré foulée vénissiane qu'en soirée
dès le matin et ça a été compliqué parce
ne vont pas de passeport ils ne
gagnaient pas nous comprendre qu'on ne
veut pas de documents donc suppléer et 9
rebonds
ne venez pas c'est la fin de l'an par
trois recettes et ses compagnons de
voyage apprend qu'il se rendrait fou les
faits pas facile je regrette mais je
n'en sais rien
si je vois comment est mon pays à ceux
de mon pays c'est parfait mais je n'ai
pas le choix
[Musique]
mais rossi insiste et en voyant notre
caméra les fonctionnaires finissent par
céder
[Musique]
les laissez-passer à mai la famille
s'est dirigé vers la gare de toulouse
prochaine étape les normes et la
colombie c'est la région bananière du
pays une région des gares forces
économiques
sur les rives du golfe de là bas toureau
une petite ville d'environ nous cent
mille habitants
c'est ici qu'est l'autoroute
panaméricains vers le nom enfin les
prochains tronçon de la route se fera
par voie maritime
au délà et le tampon de d'alien les
bouchons dus devient une jungle
inhospitalière qui sépare la colombie le
panama
[Musique]
derrière les commerces et la prospérité
de tout repos ces caches contre elle
était frappante la tranquillité les
autorités sont menacés par des groupes
criminels transnationaux très puissant
la position géostratégique de la région
favorisent de commerce international
mais elle favorise aussi des activités
criminelles comme le passage de drogue
les colonel antonio dingue on combat les
criminels dans ces deux régions
ils étaient conscients des risques
qu'ils courent les migrants qui se
dirige vers le panama
je pense qu'il faut trouver une façon de
rendre ces pays viable que le rêve
américain soit celui de vivre dans son
propre pays avec sa culture sa langue et
ses coutumes et avec des opportunités de
travail d'éducation
c'est dans cette région dangereuse
careep le petit goût des réfugiés
congolais
rochette et ses amis s'installe dans une
petite pension à turbo ils ont appris
qu'ils la frontière avec le panama est
fermé pour les migrants et qu'il ait pas
selon gonfler leur pic au passé normal
c'est 30 de rabais
ces gens là qui est des gens pour
progresser demande sens à certains de
leurs vingt personnes et aussi la
remettant pas aussi mais nous n'avions
pas encore accepté la passion se trouve
non loin du port les congolais sont pris
à partie la nuit porte quel moment
sauf qu'il faut attendre brossette
combat l'épuisement
elle doit faire preuve d'imagination
pour nourrir sa famille tout en
s'occupant des enfants sont très
fatigués toutefois nous tentons de les
expliquer et pour qu'il comprenne
comment est la situation mais on prend
quand même un titre il ne comprend rien
la plus grande joie si jamais
ce que je pensais maison avec ma famille
tu pourras les messins pas l'école
pour éviter la tente certains migrants
tentent de se glisser parmi les
touristes et la population locale les
pari est risqué
la marine colombienne a intensifié sa
puissance
les troyens d'enseignants commune pour
éviter les contres d'autres milan
préfèrent placer leur vie entre les
mains de passeurs il a mis aux arrêts
les naufrages sont fréquents à bord de
six embarcations souvent mal emplettes
unis une mort certaine pour ceux qui
n'ont pas la chance d'être rescapés
[Musique]
au cimetière local les tombes de
migrants non identifié témoin de cette
réalité comme catholiques
je fais une prière pour que dieu
pardonne leur péché après tout ils sont
humains la route des migrants c'est ça
aussi l'anonymat
même après la mort de leur vie pour un
sentier il s'efforce à le traverser
parfois il se moi ou quelqu'un est tué
finalement plusieurs se retrouvent ici
seul dans le cimetière sans que personne
pleurent leurs morts
la famille qui est loin crois qu'ils
sont arrivés à destination
voilà qui sont ici de ces histoires
d'horreur en tournant et davies martinez
aguilar est un compagnon de voyage ont
payé très cher leur rêve d'atteindre le
nord
[Musique]
descendre aurès et journaliste il sut
avec un télé les histoires des migrants
c'est ici où on a retrouvé les cadavres
des cubains quoi ils sont partis la nuit
quand il était proche du marais le
capitaine du bateau a fait un détour
les cubains ne s'attendait pas à ça les
pacers ont alors sorti un pistolet et
une machette et un couteau et ils leur
ont dit on va vous volez rôle dramatique
ocha les bras droit on a retrouvé les
corps ici flottant dans les marais et
d'elvis a été violée a plus cherché pis
elle a été égorgé son corps blanc main
découper au couteau
l'incident a changé la donne pour les
trafiquants de migrants
les assassins ont été arrêtés et seront
accusés de meurtre
les migrants ont peur quand il arrive
dans la région ils demandent s'ils vont
être en sécurité
si quelque chose peut leur arriver ils
ont peur de vivre la même chose que ces
cubains c'est dans ce contexte que sa
famille et leurs amis congolais prennent
le large
quelque part sur la côte à l'abri des
autorités nous partons à leur charge
la navigation sur de la mer des caraïbes
pu être des liseuses
les embarcations sont souvent mal
entretenus et les pannes sont fréquents
c'est dans les villages des caps il y en
a qui nous finissons par les jaunes deux
rouges secs et son globe qui laissa pas
nager cela m'était encore de
l'expérience
fatalement les mandats et terry
lorsqu'il ya
les vagues
ce camp je suis encore tremblante les
plaques ce que j'avais là l'eau avec
ballet n'a vu encore j'en ai un projet
trombe
aujourd'hui gêné pour
ma vie
les habits mouiller je ne rien
mais je sais que tu es encore me
retourne
cd je perds
[Musique]
oudjit reconsidère capot rihanna comme
un paradis sur terre située sur les
rives de la mer des caraïbes
si villa s'est entourée par la jungle
c'est tout régions pluvieuses coller à
la frontière avec le panama
maury montayral des moines et la force
et l'éternel
afin de poursuivre leur route vers le
nord les migrants doivent traverser les
gens le doyen les panama a augmenté ses
contrôles dans les rues de refouler les
migrants rosé et chang il vient grossir
les rangs des centaines de migrants qui
sont bloqués ici à temps pour cannes à
vienne on a quand même une ligne
il nous arrive avec des enfants et des
femmes enceintes
selon edgar mejia
ils sont plus de 350 migrants les
villages presque 10% de la population
notre principale préoccupation c'est la
santé des villageois srd immigrants
sommes 4500 personnes en tout nous
n'avons que médecins et deux infirmières
ça ne suffit pas on devrait avoir trois
ou quatre médecins nous ne les avons pas
il ne devrait pas passer par ici ça me
brise le coeur de dire ça ce sont des
êtres humains à la recherche d'une vie
meilleure
difficile pour les migrants décédés
simulé d'un sont si petits villages nous
cherchons pas par des paroles comme ce
n'est pas les retrouver sur les bords de
la mer il n'attend qu'une seule chose
départ de la route
oh
procède s'accroche à l'espoir que du
panama ou bleu bilto sa frontière
d'autres comme nicolas miguet anciens
ont décidé de tenter leur chance
après avoir un beau chien en passant et
part que les dangereux sentiers qu'ici
dans la jungle
nicolas et sa famille des trois enfants
ont été refoulés
j'ai fait trois jours quatre jours
marcher dans les forêts et trois nuits
ont peu d'eau dans les forêts et le
magic et le fond ciel se fait mais les
polices mal tourné juste ici à cabourg
ghana sera payé au point qu'on plie de
100 $ pour mâcher ou dans les forêts
privées sur le summum c'est mon agent a
prédit aussi quand mon agent
en attendant qui sait contrôler relâche
ni que la décharge des bateaux pour
nourrir sa famille je vais chercher
quelque chose pour matri modèle en
famille je vais acheter zeri aux
poissons ce sport confirme en ce moment
mon enfant en art majeur et j'espère y
six coups pour solutionner ce canal
ouvrir les frontières je vais continuer
mon disque alréens à l'âge
je traverserai pas cette jungle avec des
enfants c'est trop dur
un adulte c'est ce qu'il veut mais pas
un enfant peut pas le droit d'en était
enfant vers la mort parce que c'est un
chemin meurtrier a des liens non connais
bien les conditions dans la jungle
il vient d'être refoulés pour leucate
d'une fois comme il a la nourriture
c'est ça qui est vital de l'autre on
trouve partout
s'ils traversent le fleuve 100 fois la
nourriture c'est de l'or sur la route
vêtements les ustensiles la nourriture
qui est important pour la montagne tu
dois tout jeter sauf la nourriture
quitte à nous et aux cybercafés qu'il
est toujours vivant
pour les prendre il doit leur demander
de l'argent pour payer à nouveau les
passants une logique qui dérange mais
les villageois
même si la frontière est fermée
les passeurs d amen et les militaires
les ramène à cas pour gagner ces
histoires finissent par décourager
recettes
l'accord se prolonge et l'argent
commence à m'inquiéter
nous avions que nous sommes restés avec
nous avions pour n'est pas aussi les
dossiers parce qu'ils comptent opel
hôtel en fait rien
on fait que manger ça on n'avance pas
pour moi je voulais qu'on avance qu'on
est en avant mais malheureusement comme
le fautif on ne peut rien nous allons
attendre
c'est une déception pour moi brochen est
bonne donc pas plus longtemps chez relay
q les quêtes un peu l'air pouvant donner
j'avais mon idée
j'avais mon idée est d'arriver jusqu'au
bout ah non à mon objectif et même après
1,2 moi j'arrivais toujours
j'ai l'espoir et la foi bronches et est
aussi inquiète elle a impliqué le chemin
qui traverse la jungle est surnommée la
route de la mort dans la jungle
il ya eu de mauvais moments les montées
et descentes sont difficiles
plusieurs meurent sur le chemin d'un
infarctus de blessures ou de mort sur
même les militaires toutes les
conditions dans la jungle difficile et
souffle parfois des maladies graves
si cela arrive à nos soldats qui sont
bien entraînés et qui ont de bons
supports minsk has
imaginez-vous ce qui arrive à ces
migrants sont physiquement affaibli une
marche dans cette jungle sous une
température à laquelle ils ne sont pas
habitués et sur des sentiers qu'ils ne
connaissent pas et qui sont très
difficiles à parcourir
ou découvrir ceux qui attendront c'est
lorsqu'il reprendra son chemin vers le
canada nous avons décidé de nous
aventurer sur l'un des nombreux sentiers
des légendes du darien les guides
touristiques où ils berthod et des
pinceaux et or nous accompagneront ce
dernier a exigé l'anonymat
dehors je suis un paysan est un multi
qui travaille sur la montagne les
migrants passés et je les retrouvais
souvent perdus dans la jungle
j'ai commencé par les aider à se rendre
au sommet de la montagne et maintenant
je le fais à plein temps
[Musique]
les migrants partout au milieu de la
nuit
c'est le meilleur moment pour edu et les
autorités pour assurer notre sécurité
il a fallu obtenir la permission du club
de golf la mafia locale qui contrôle ce
territoire
la traversée de la chambre peut prendre
de trois à six jours ou plus encore tout
dépend des conditions des sentiers et
des passeurs son marchand bon rythme
on va arriver à la frontière dans huit
heures là ya un endroit pour dormir ou
normalement les gens qu'on sent pas seul
impossible de savoir comment ni pas où
se diriger c'est un saut dans l'inconnu
l'avis du que le p4 et les mêmes de
notre guy et de passeur on vient de
franchir la première étape souvent les
migrants sont très fatigués et on
s'arrête une demi-heure avant de
continuer
[Applaudissements]
il faut que les migrants monte encore
trois étapes de plus pour atteindre le
sommet de la montagne
plus la journée avance plus la chaleur
et l'humidité sont insupportables les
long des sentiers d'événements abandonné
et des restes l'emballage laissés par
les migrants donc si les gens ne se
sentent pas bien il faut les attendre il
ya des guides y impose un rythme effréné
aux migrants ils sont irresponsables
les passeurs doivent être sur le qui
vive pour les animaux sauvages qui
pouvait surprendre les migrants et les
scorpions venimeux et les serpents qui
ces cages le long des sentiers la
frontière avec le panama est encore loin
c'est une personne sur trop fou y aller
doucement se reposer chaque 10 minutes
et s'asseoir avec eux si on ne fait pas
des gens peuvent mourir à cause de
l'effort à montréal notamment
les morgues dressent sur la route ce
sont les paysans qui attire les cadavres
les long des sentiers progressivement
les délais des difficultés augmentent
les pentes les liens de plus en plus
incliné la pluie des derniers jours les
ascensions difficiles
les migrants qui atteignent la frontière
du panama c'est et saufs
ça c'est fait le prendre par des
patrouilles sont soulagés ils sont
soulevés qu à la section la plus
dangereuse de la jambe des passeurs que
l'on bien rempli ces images elles
servent de pleuvent et les migrants ont
été livrés vivant aux pacers span amène
les clubs du golfe les narco trafiquants
qui contrôlent la région exige pleuvent
dépit la mort brutale de la jeune
cubaine un turbo ces groupes armés fixe
parfois des conditions et il s'agit de
ne pas dépasser les limites
même s'il ya toujours une marge de
manoeuvre parfois ils décident des
routes et des sentiers que les passeurs
doivent utiliser et cela se respecte
comme ça tout le monde travaille
gilberte notre guide connaît bien
l'équilibré délicat qui conserve la paix
dans ces territoires
après tout la pauvreté dans la région et
l'arrivée massive des migrants ont fait
en sorte que n'importe qui peut
s'improviser pas ça parfois des enfants
de 12 13 et 15 ans ont guidé des groupes
de dix ou quinze migrants d'autres
personnes gagnent peu d'argent en aidant
les migrants qui sont trop fatigués
apporter leurs valises béret tout dacca
pour le ghana nous nous préparons à
partie d'un nouveau un guide des
migrants africains de l'auberge
péniblement la junte
nous voulons les rattraper
de l'autre côté de la frontière
nous contournons la jungle via la mer
des caraïbes cédric est plus
dispendieuses et peu utilisés par les
migrants les contrôles migratoires se
fait à obaldia au panama l'élu de ces
petits villages sont desserte la
fermeture de la frontière a limité le
flot des migrants
l'an dernier l'arrivée massive des
migrants avaient déclenchée une urgence
sanitaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parsemer les longues du littoral désir
habité par deux membres du peuple künast
les villages sont proches des
stylistique du panama c'est cet automne
en plusieurs fois sauvé la vie des
migrants qui se sont égarés
c'est aussi palissy qu'est la mafia
chinoise fait passer ses clients qui
paient le gros prix
après deux heures de navigation
nous atteignons la côte du panama peu
après l'arrivée
il faut se soumettre le contrôle routier
toujours aucun signe du goût d'aimer
classe africain
nous poursuivons notre chemin vers l'est
nord
[Musique]
pas sûr qu'à noël une ville frontière
partagée par le panama et le costa rica
c'est une zone commerciale qui attire
des gens du pays
c'est aussi la porte d'entrée des
migrants en route vers l'amérique du
nord
[Musique]
le
tout en dressant des chemins de campagne
permet au patient de contourner les
contrôles routiers
mais depuis qu'il est gouvernement
costaricain offre aux migrants des
laissez-passer pour circuler librement
certes on peut utiliser au costa rica
les passeurs comme carlos son dommage
on peut dire que les affaires sont
mortes un migrant avec un laissez-passer
préfèrent traverser le pays en autobus
que payer pour un service trois fois
plus cher
[Musique]
les pays a aussi ouvert des cas pour
offrir un nom à 6 sur réfugiés comme
celui-ci à l'extérieur tes passions
canoas dans le centre on y re dompter la
nourriture hommes s'occupent des malades
et nos frais des soins psychologiques
pour les aider à surmonter les
traumatismes qu'ils auraient pu vivre à
la jungle on va être prêt pour savoir si
il y à des personnes qui arrivent dans
une mauvaise condition la situation ou
pas au niveau physique mais maintenant
ça c'est très stressant être arrêté dans
c'est une forêt ça ne rien manger sans
rien voir
ok de l'eau de la rivière et c'est un
connaître qu'est ce qu'elle est un futur
yolanda sanabia est officiellement
traductrice mais elle est beaucoup plus
que cela appelle moi mais mes me dit tu
me vois maintenant comme ça mais
vraiment je suis sale mais bt mons en
salle il ya des jours que je peux pas
changer mes vêtements
mais j'ai deux états comme ça même si tu
me vois je suis plus après prennent une
douche avoir des vêtements de nouveau
c'est différent mais moi je sais pas moi
mais je sais par une mauvaise personne
autant de facteurs
[Applaudissements]
cet hôtel du nord du costaricain qui
nous trouvons des membres du groupe
d'africains qui ont traversé la jambe d
peine et de misère 15 jours 15 jours
dans les forêts ya des gens il ya les
autres et familles qui viennent tu vois
pas pas moi on arrête avec les mamans
avec les enfants moi je vis une autre
fille de 35 ans mort devant nous et
ensemble si je savais que ça a été comme
ça je ne pouvais pas venir se faire mais
on était on est arrivés dgc qu'est ce
qu'on va faire pour continuer pour moi
omar histoire d'héritage un homme
d'héripré criait au jour de l'abandonner
y'avait pas continuer il y avait décidé
de cesser mourir je crois qu'ils mordent
300 concerts et possède jungle à mon
pire ennemi c'est très dangereux
des journées éprouvantes pour ceux qui
s'occupent de ces migrants les histoires
laisse des marques indélébiles et
antérieurement nationale y est ils nous
ont raconté comment trois personnes
d'origine indienne qui était dans la
jungle du derrien se sont fait attaquer
par des gens de la mafia qui les ont
poignardés c'est très difficile pour
nous au niveau émotionnel
parce qu'il raconte c'est avec beaucoup
de sentiments dans leur coeur et il faut
se mettre à leur place c'est très triste
de les entendre raconter leur histoire
est de savoir que plusieurs de leurs
amis n'arrive jamais jusqu'ici mieux que
retourner à la guerre
alors c'est parce que jamais je pourrais
ne suivaient pas même je vais pas être
habitué à écouter ses histoires chaque
fois que j'écoute un jt wang
je deviens sommes pas fâchés avec le
monde
fâché avec la guerre mais je veux que ça
continue comme ça je ne vais pas à
normaliser sa aline et au costa rica des
plus que l'esc et toi moi et le voyage
avec ses enfants
ils n'arrivent pas à côté de la route
font le régal du voile via ses
sentiments parfois contradictoires
qu'ils accompagnent les coulages la peur
la douleur et la fois
[Musique]
un jour ça ira kythera ici personne ne
restera ici et 1
une partie de son coeur est resté à tout
jamais dans leur langue ou la liste
c'est sort s'est noyé dans la rivière
jamais personne pour nous aider si avec
quelqu'un pouvait bien là la rattrape et
l'on ne sait pas nager
et puis à des gros rochers dans la
rivière là bas on ne sait pas nager on
ne savait pas la rattraper et elle est
partie comme ça à 35 enfants halim
appuyé sur saône et les enfants dessin
soir qu'en pense à elle ça nous donne ça
nous renforce
on s'est dit on fait ça pour elle en sa
mémoire si elle était l'allosaure
courage et aline est une leader naturel
qui a dû fuir chantepie les congo restée
gravée dans ses pensées et d'accès vers
si on voit au canada c'est pas par
plaisir
on aimerait bien rester chaud selon les
murs mais on s'est dit un jour peut-être
on rentrait à cheyrou dans l'entreprise
où il travaille et sensibiliser nos
frais qui sont restés là bas comme la
grande majorité des africains qui
séjournent dans ces camps aline croit
que le canada et son premier ministre
des vrais faut faire plus pour qu'ils ne
soient pas obligés d'abandonner leurs
pays j'aimerais qu'ils puissent eux qui
commencent déjà sanctionné le président
sanguinaire d'afrique faut pas les
encourager faut commencer à le
sélectionner tout simplement
mais les conditions en afrique ne vont
pas changer d'os mais aline les autres
nigra essaye de traverser la frontière
avec le nicaragua et continuer vers
l'est nord
mais ce n'est pas facile on nous dit bon
voilà pour vous aider mais il ya des
gens des passeurs on arrive ici j'étais
nicard avoir deux fois déjà donné des
armes et de l'argent de 300 dollars 72,3
annulant les passeurs sont un nouveau
protagoniste et nous abandonner là il
est parti et plus l'auteur de deux ans
disparaît le tdb d'ici paris
lenny turin voix est devenue une étape
difficile à franchir
argent qui commence chamakh et rend la
tâche encore plus complexe les familles
en afrique n'ont plus les moyens de les
supporter les restes canadienne se
transforment parfois un cauchemar
quant à rochette elle a repris la route
et se rapproche de son but mais sans
argent
sept migrants du congolais ne sait pas
s'il pourra se battre jusqu'au canada
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces images ont été tournées à l'aider
comme elle à cacher nous sommes un
peignage blanca l'une des portes
d'entrée du nicaragua ici les
journalistes qui s'intéressent à la
question des méga ne sont pas bienvenus
la raison les pays a déclaré la guerre
aux migrants les autorités comme sud les
sans papiers comme une menace à la
sécurité nationale ils sont déployées
les forces de l'ordre pour protéger les
pays à nous il est 17 plus des saints
mais migrants ont été arrêtés net à
l'abri même pas les citoyens du pays
je ne suis pas son trafiquante le
procureur m'a accusé de trafic
international de micro jeux les
accompagner comme l'aurait fait une mère
mais je ne les jamais aidé à traverser
la frontière
[Musique]
me lemaire à lehman vohra habite le
village de san juan de sous un jour
francesca une migrante haïtiens se
présente chez elle avec sa petite fille
noémie fiévreuse où normalement on
souligne la mère m'a demandé si je
pouvais sauver sa fille
mendenhall ali l'enfant était en très
mauvaises conditions
benny hill était recouverte des piqûres
d'insectes et admis après avoir aidé la
migrante ni la marque se retrouve en
état d'arrestation
accusé de trafic humain il passe car
ainsi jouera pison hama pendant son
procès j'ai été condamné
les procureurs a exigé dix ans mais le
juge l'a réduit à 5
les habitants du village de san juan del
sources ont manifesté pendant des jours
jusqu'à ce qu'ils les juges à corps
d'annie la mare ou une libération
conditionnelle
à son retour près de 3000 personnes
s'étaient rassemblées pour l'accueillir
[Musique]
francesca et noémie ont été déportés
vers le costa rica à l'aide d'un passeur
elles sont prêts plus le chemin et ont
contourné le nicaragua un bateau
jusqu'au bout reste c'est la route à
plus de paris sept et sa famille après
un arrêt de moins
rochette et godet ont repris la route et
on peut affronter la jungle du d'aliens
nous avons passé sept jours dans le jour
7 jours par des joints vous allez
marcher six jours c'est toujours à pied
comme ce matin jusqu'au soir
si un peu la nourriture vous mourrez de
faim
je n'ai je n'avais pas pensé à ça
c'était voile des risques parce que même
les montants là il ya des pierres qui se
glisse un il doit y aller monter comme
ça et les descentes comme ça et abbas et
la rivière
donc quand j'ai glissé lentement vous
battez la tête qui m'ont effet pas
concéder gens pour venir en sortant de
la jambe
ils ont fait la route jusqu'au costa
rica c'est god et les manies des
rochettes qui a documenté la suite du
voyage
la route après avoir contourné les
nicaragua la famille a traversé le
honduras ils sont ensuite franchi la
frontière roi tu es malade puis ils ont
continué leur chemin vers le mexique
arrivé à la frontière ils sont traversé
la rivière fiat et à l'inde au big one à
une ville de deux millions d'habitants
située face à san diego en californie
des milliers de migrants ont incité par
cette région frontalière à la poursuite
de leur rêve une frontière non seulement
protégé par un mur mais aussi par des
patrouilles américaines qui font les va
et vient à longueur de journée quatre
mois après avoir quitté sao paulo au
brésil
brossette et sa famille arrive à diwan à
la maison d'amy gars au sud du mexique
leur a donné de nouveau big mac pour
remplacer ce qu'il portait depuis les
débuts de ses voyages nous sommes si
johanna nous
nous n'allons pas aller à l'hôtel parce
qu'il fait économiser le fait que nous
restons mais ne savons pas comment serré
la suite pour au canada après avoir payé
l'épaisseur l'état sport marja comment
se maquiller ils doivent faire des
économies la famille s'installe à la
maison d'amy g de tijuana la chambre
[Musique]
de l'année la famille célesto la
curiosité est trop forte
il se rend à la frontière pour voir ce
mur qui sépare les états unis du mexique
ce mur qui les sépare de leurs rêves
le couple profite aussi du moment pour
distraire les enfants pauline et mari et
son fils onesta d'insouciance
il ya un sentiment de rejet ici à la
frontière messages de haine et
d'exclusion
j'y mets les crocs et professeur
d'université a dit croire et à 110 euros
il s'intéresse en liga 6 soit 6 des
sûretés les murs depuis dix ans cette
femme travaille avec des étudiants et
des groupes sociaux pour documenter les
passages des migrants ces documents sont
fascinants ce que je recueille
appartiennent à des migrants qui sont
venus de l'inde quand ils traversent la
frontière ils n'ont plus besoin de ses
papiers
alors ils traversent et ils peuvent dire
qu'ils n'ont pas de papiers je n'ai rien
avec moi
recette ego des nouvelles à tout prix
éviter les postes frontaliers américains
de peur d'être déportés ils n'ont pas
les moyens de s'offrir les services d'un
passeur qui peuvent coûter jusqu'à
treize mille dollars
mes recettes ne perd pas espoir avec
goudé et l'a décidé dès bientôt partir
pour mes volets rideaux et traversé la
frontière au texas à cet endroit il n'y
a pas de mur fossé battre dans la vie
il faut souvient tous les moyens
possibles pour s'en sortir ce soit même
j'ai doublé tous les parcours qu'ils
aient toutes les souffrances je les ai
oubliés
j'aimerais maintenant les positifs de ce
qu'ils aiment à réserver
on chip n'a pas regretté son choix la
famille a réussi à traverser la
frontière
inégalement à laredo au texas sain et
sauf
après avoir été placé en état
d'arrestation
ils ont été relâchés
[Musique]
après plus de quatre mois sur la route
la fatigue s'accumule connais plus le
jour la date les trajets en autobus est
long mais l'arrivée au canada est
presque palpable jeudi que je sois l'a
bien finie la barre pays
je vais travailler comme toute personne
qui travaille qui cherche sa vie
j'ai aussi étudié qui vais m'organiser
ce parce que c'est là que je vais rester
pour nos plus violents de ma vie
la prochaine étape plattsburgh dans
l'état de new york
de là ils pourront prendre le taxi
jusqu'à la frontière canadienne
mais la famille n'a plus d'argent dro
s'est développée entre sunrise canadien
en suspens
c'est sur la route vers place pour que
nous avons rencontré adam un jeune
nigérienne en route vers le canada
adam est arrivé à new york un avion muni
d'un visa étudiant avant de quitter le
nigeria il avait la ferme intention de
se rendre au québec il nomine commencé à
apprendre quelques mots de passe et un
comme ça va ça va bien mais si je
m'appelais dire habite
buju
ou soir entre la loi de nos matches
arrivé à plaques secours à dan est
accostée par un chauffeur de taxi
les chauffeurs prendre des campagnes qui
s'arrête à la frontière
c'est ici qu'est la dame traverse
illégalement au canada
l'immigration qui fut créé en syrie ont
du reste robuste à la route des migrants
est en elle-même un personnage à part
entière bien vivante en constante
évolution
elle réagit aux événements à
l'environnement et aux personnes qui la
fréquentent
difficile de calculer la quantité des
migrants sans papiers qui ont traversé
le continent américain du sco canada
qu'est-ce qu'il s'est vite les contrôles
après avoir voyagé pour devenir km
procède pas toujours d'arriver au canada
mais une question hante son esprit sain
bel âge une fois arrivé à destination
c'est la terre accepter ou de refoulé à
la frontière
[Musique]